All right.
So today the question we're going to deal with is the survival of the Roman
Empire in the east.
Why did the empire based in Constantinople survive?
Whereas as we saw last week,
the western empire based nominally in Rome Times in Milan and times in Ravenna
collapsed in the fifth century,
we're going to take a long view of survival in the east.
That is from the fifth century to the mid 19th century.
Uh,
after the mid 19th century,
the eastern Roman empire flourishes and has a period,
uh,
that we will discuss in a few weeks of great splendor and prosperity.
Uh,
but,
uh,
this long view is justified by the fact that four for 400 years or so,
this eastern Roman empire faced tremendous threats of invasion,
uh,
sieges
difficulties dealing with all sorts of nations and peoples and at the same time,
internal division because of religious controversy or what are the people who
one called heresies?
I remind you that while we call it the eastern Roman empire or the Byzantine
Empire,
they called themselves the Roman Empire.
No adjective,
no qualification.
They were the successor to,
and if they were the only successor,
tough luck.
They were the successor to the empire of Augustus,
the empire of Diocletian,
the empire of constant team in their base
before the seventh century.
They were,
as you see on the map,
the map really shows the more or less at their height eastern Roman empire.
Notice that it goes as far as Spain
in the Mediterranean.
This was the accomplishment of Justinian an emperor of the sixth century who,
whose reign Mark's a kind of apogee height of power of this empire,
uh,
within this period of crisis.
So while I'm saying that we're dealing with,
uh,
about four centuries worth of sieges and crises.
There is this a period in the sixth century in the reign of Justinian,
uh,
who,
represents a kind of brief but very important reconquest of the West.
And that's partly what you're seeing,
at least the leftovers of it in this map.
Uh,
that shows you the Byzantine or Rome,
eastern Roman Empire in the year 600 extending including Spain,
North Africa,
the coast of what's now Libya,
uh,
Egypt,
the Mediterranean,
Middle East.
That is modern Israel,
uh,
Syria,
Lebanon,
Anatolia,
that is to say Asia minor,
modern Turkey and the Balkans,
Greece and the Aegean islands.
This empire was held together by Constantinople,
which as you see,
and as we've already spoken about,
is strategically placed to control access between Europe and Asia across the
Bosphorus Straits and also between the Black Sea,
which is the access point to Central Asia and the Mediterranean Sea.
This city,
modern Istanbul still has the walls built by Theodocia is the second in the
early fifth century.
The so-called Theodosian walls rather,
uh,
nastily restored recently are a,
an incredible monument,
uh,
still in their ruined state to the power of Constantinople as they
were built on the landward side.
Constantinople,
very difficult to attack from the sea and because of the walls,
very difficult to attack from the land.
Uh,
until very recently,
that is,
I would say,
until the 1980s,
the Theodosian walls,
we're not reached by the urban agglomeration of Istanbul.
That is,
they were so big and so far from the main center of the city that only in recent
decades has Istanbul,
which is one of the fastest growing and most prosperous cities in the region has
the city sort of,
uh,
leapfrogged over the walls and the walls are now kind of in the midst of a new
part of the city.
Nevertheless,
uh,
extremely impressive accomplishment and the period we're dealing with is mostly
sieges of Constantinople and heresies.
And if you could just hold that in your mind,
this somewhat one event after another that I never heard of quality that this
will have,
I think will be,
if not alleviated,
at least rendered comprehensible.
Before we go on,
let me just say a few words about pro copious who has read the secret history
before.
Okay,
so not,
not too much,
and you should have started it.
I should have warned you.
It has,
um,
uh,
disturbing a,
even a weirdly pornographic parts.
Um,
it is a diatribe against the emperor Justinian.
I don't think I'm giving anything away by saying that pro copious,
his theory about Justinian is that he's a demon or devil.
Uh,
a representative of how,
what makes this text interesting is it's an intimate portrayal even if it may
not be an accurate one,
but we will pay a certain price.
We are willing to pay a certain price for intimacy,
for immediacy,
for the sense of an extremely sinister court.
It's a little bit like reading about Stalin or some other capricious,
extremely powerful,
a hard working but bloodthirsty ruler.
I think what you have to ask yourself is,
uh,
how could a ruler of this particular time and polity not be blood thirsty?
What seems to be per copious as problem?
And uh,
you know,
I don't expect anything but will elucidate some answers on Wednesday per copious
in part is interesting because all of his other works are lavish in their praise
of Justinian.
This is a,
an historian who knows nothing between panegyric and,
uh,
diatribe.
Nothing between lavish survival praise and,
um,
the harshest imaginable criticism.
The two go together.
The two are phenomena again of absolute test courts from that of Louis the 14th,
uh,
to that of,
um,
20th century dictators.
The same kind of enforced praise,
uh,
can create a kind of humiliation and a rage that comes out in other forms.
The secret history had to be secret because had the authorities read a few words
of this per copious would have not died in bed as indeed he did.
We know this from one manuscript in the Vatican found in the 17th century.
Okay.
So that's my introduction to prick opiates.
When we talk about survival of the east,
we're talking about survival under several different kinds of circumstances.
So our,
um,
our first concern is how did the east survive the fifth century,
which destroyed the western Roman Empire?
Part of the answer is geography.
The east was easier to defend,
especially as I've just said,
the position of Constantinople,
both as an impregnable site and as a,
uh,
commercial city with very,
very extensive trade and as a base to defend the two core territories of the
empire.
By core territories,
I mean that,
you know,
really the essential parts of this empire,
which are the Balkans,
including Greece under that rubric for the moment and Asia Minor.
And of course,
Constantinople is ideally placed to protect both of them.
Other advantages of the east over the West,
a bit richer,
more urbanized,
produced,
more taxable revenues than the West.
It's army didn't fall apart.
Uh,
it's civilian structure of administration remained intact
with the exception Justinian very few of these emperors are that outstanding in
their abilities,
but
their subordinates were very capable,
but government worked well.
And,
uh,
the east survived a number of powerful threats from the outside,
from the outside,
meaning it had the same problem as the Roman Empire in an admittedly smaller and
more defensible space.
It had an eastern frontier and it had a northern frontier,
both of which were a
fragile,
the eastern frontier with Persia or talking about them,
talked about them and the northern frontier along the Danube river,
more or less,
uh,
with all sorts of different peoples from the Avrs,
Slavs,
bull,
gars,
all sorts of,
uh,
um,
nations that would attack it.
It also had the disadvantage of internal religious dissent,
and we're going to be talking more about this.
These problems eventually did affect the east adversely.
It would have a period of pretty radical decline,
not so different from that of the West beginning in the seventh century,
this decline can be seen in the abandonment of many cities or they're much
smaller population.
We've already seen that as a feature of the West in the loss of territory.
We're going to be talking about Islam and the Arab conquests,
but they begin in the seventh century and very quickly result in the loss from
the Byzantine point of view of Egypt and the Mediterranean Near East,
but unlike the west of the Byzantine or east Roman government never collapsed in
the face of these threats.
Although it is a kind of period of cultural decline,
certainly a period of military defeats of sieges of political problems and of
religious dissent.
Nevertheless,
the empire would survive.
Hm.
In general,
during this period,
what unites these 400 years?
We're talking about roughly four 50 to eight 50 is the ability of the empire to
resist invasions.
It's willingness to accept the loss of certain provinces while protecting
others.
And it's a domination of Constantinople over its region.
At the opening of our periods,
cities like Alexandria and Antioch are extremely important,
uh,
their importance within the byzantine empire declines.
Okay.
But in order to understand some of the internal problems,
we're going to have to talk about Harris Cs.
I think I already apologized for having to talk about heresies and I think I
already explained why it's important.
Questions,
remarks.
Denunciations um,
okay.
Representatives of the,
uh,
iconic class defense fund.
Wanna claim equal time.
Okay.
Um,
this is just a selection of Harrison's,
right?
I mean,
we're just,
we're just this the proverbial tip of the iceberg,
the proverbial icing on the cake.
Uh,
the proverbial,
um,
what do you call it?
A,
you know,
crust on the chocolate pudding.
But having said that,
uh,
these two are what are called Christological controversies there about the
nature of Christ
is the relationship of his human to divine nature and grossly to oversimplify,
then historians emphasize Christ's divine nature and the Manasseh sites,
Christ's human nature.
The beginning of this controversy is with the historians.
The patriarch named after the Patriarch Nestorius,
the Bishop Patriarch of Constantinople.
Okay.
Nestorius seemed to teach and he's patriarch in the,
uh,
for 30 days,
four twenties.
And the stories would be deposed in four 30.
One as patriarch,
his followers seemed to teach that,
uh,
Christ was fully human
and that his divine nature was either separate from his human nature or,
uh,
it was,
um,
nonexistent or irrelevant.
I should remind you that the problem is posed by Christ being God and yet being
crucified and suffering and dying.
So this is a problem that logically arises out of an understanding of who Christ
is and what he does for humanity.
Mysteries was deposed by the third ecumenical council of Constantinople.
Uh,
um,
I'm sorry,
third Ecumenical Council,
which meets in FSS on the western shore of Asia Minor Council of FSS Ecumenical
Council.
The third one in four 31,
the first two had dealt with Arianism.
I'll remind you that Arianism is a different problem because it deals not with
the nature of Christ,
but the relationship of Christ to God.
The father here,
we're now just concentrating on Christ.
The Manasseh sites in opposing the historians naturally emphasized Christ's
divine nature as the historians had,
in their opinion,
overemphasized the human nature.
But from the point of view of the
group that we can call Orthodox,
the people who believed neither in the story in Ism nor monophysitism both sides
were extremists.
The Manasseh Sites overdid Christ's divine nature.
If the historians taught that Christ had two natures.
Yeah.
A kind of human,
fully human one and a fully divine one that were separate.
The Manasseh sites seemed to be teaching or did teach that Christ had one nature
and that essentially divine
the relationship of the,
um,
human and divine natures and monophysitism was denounced by their opponents as
if you threw a bucket of water into the ocean.
The bucket of water representing the human part.
Yeah.
What's at stake in this and why it's important is how Christ saves people.
If he is to human,
then he's just a human elevated by God,
like some kind of ancient world hero
and he doesn't seem then to have the power to save people from the devil.
Hell original sin,
all of these terrible things that God has saved the followers of Christ from.
If he's divine,
completely divine,
then what's the point of distinguishing him from God the Father?
And then how did he suffer on the cross?
What's his suffering real?
Can God with no human elements suffer?
Okay.
Questions about this so far?
Yeah,
we understand the difference then.
And we sort of understand what's at stake sort of,
because maybe we're thinking,
I hope not because you're not in the medieval frame of mind.
If you're thinking this,
you may be thinking vo nonetheless.
Well,
why don't they just agree to disagree
or something like,
Hey,
you can believe in one nature all believe in too.
Or you can believe in two separate nature's all believe in two natures,
uh,
coexisting and you know,
um,
God will reward your good intentions.
That's really the problem is that we live in a society in which,
uh,
at least two.
So we may think enlightened people don't really impose their beliefs.
Uh,
um,
in detail on others.
We're not really interested in theology that much,
but the Bible I've got to admit,
does say that it is important to have the right belief,
but by boat particularly,
but not exclusively.
The Old Testament is very bad on rewarding good intentions.
The further back you go in the Bible,
the less our good intentions rewarded.
Lot's wife was told not to look back.
She looked back,
she was turned into a pillar of salt.
Nobody said,
oh,
okay.
You didn't mean to look back,
you know,
or,
or human weakness.
That's just it.
Or The guy.
Now I'm betraying my ignorance.
Who,
um,
uh,
drops the,
where he stumbles as they're carrying the tabernacle back to Jerusalem from
captivity,
uh,
with the Philistines.
Is it a desire?
Uh,
well,
anyway,
I shouldn't get started on things I'm not sure of,
but the guy stumbles and god strikes him dead.
He stumbled.
Nobody asks him,
Oh,
I'm sorry.
You know,
I didn't mean to stumble.
Or,
you know,
a little rabbit ran in front of me.
He stumbles,
he dies.
That's it.
God wants you to understand what's going on in so far as uh,
you don't make errors.
Therefore,
the right understanding of Christ's nature is important.
It's not just a matter of convincing other people.
You know,
that um,
one band is better than another or one kind of game is better enough there or in
one team is better than a not there it is crucial.
Gregory of Mysa himself,
a theologian writes about a 500 a day or so that the mood of theological
controversy is so great that uh,
if you go into a shop and you ask about your change,
he says the shopkeeper fell off the philosophizes about the begotten and the
unbegotten.
If you inquire about a loaf of bread,
the baker will reply that the sun is inferior and the father is superior.
And if you ask if your bath is ready,
the attendance says the sun is made out of nothing.
Now all of this is a satiric,
a remark about the way in which ordinary people are caught up in this religious
controversy.
It is not exclusively a matter of intellectuals or clergy,
but it's a political problem as well.
And that's the reason that it really preoccupies us
in the council of Kelsey done in four 51,
four 54.
So ethicists for 31 cal Seaton
for a 51 to four cal season,
also on the other side of Constantinople on the Asian side,
uh,
of uh,
what's now Turkey.
The Council of cal CDN,
uh,
denounced them an office sites.
It basically says that Christ has two natures.
They are both perfect.
They are indivisible,
but they are separate.
Two natures,
one person,
one hypostasis hypostasis is a thing that exists in its own right.
This solution was suggested by Rome,
by the pope,
the same Pope Leo,
the great who had negotiated with the hands,
but west had the advantage of not experiencing these kinds of controversies.
And so,
um,
constant and opal far more powerful than Rome in the before fifties roam about
to collapse completely,
nevertheless is beholden to Rome for at least what would be the majority
solution to the problem of monophysitism.
Of course,
actually it's not a solution because not everybody acknowledges the council of
Calcium.
It provokes a,
um,
split.
The Patriarch of Alexandria would be the leader of those resisting the council
and Egypt,
Syria.
And to some extent Lebanon and Palestine would be,
uh,
Manasseh side steadfastly.
Yeah.
Indeed.
The survivors of the Manasseh sites that,
that is the modern day representatives of this,
uh,
part of Christianity are the Copts in Egypt who formed 10% of the population
Christian in office side and the Christians of Ethiopia who form a little more
than 50% of the population of Ethiopia.
These so called Coptic Christians are the descendants of the monopoly sites.
The historians also have some scattered followers in the modern world.
They were very strong in central Asia.
And if you've studied things like the voyages of Marco Polo and other Western
travelers in the 13th century,
the people who interpret for them,
who help them,
who sort of acquaint them with central Asia and the Chinese Mongol Empire are
historians.
But we're kind of going to leave them out because they're not a political
problem for the Byzantine Empire.
They're pretty much exiled,
but comps are an internal problem.
And the the,
the Manasseh sites or cops do not like the Orthodox,
the Byzantine emperors,
try to compromise with them.
Okay.
And I'll mention a couple of these compromises.
The emperor,
uh,
uh,Z now
from a four 74,
two,
491 issued a document called the hypnotic icon.
Okay.
We're back to emperors.
As with we saw as far back as Constantine emperor is trying to intervene to
solve religious controversies,
right?
The Hanoda con,
um,
says,
okay,
one of the trinity was incarnate and we're not going to discuss it anymore.
Okay.
So first it says this rather noncommittal statement.
One of the trinity was incarnate
and then it also outlaws.
Any further discussion?
Nobody liked this.
Yeah.
Xena was succeeded by Anastasia's who was a Manasseh side.
And then as we'll see,
the great emperor of the Sixth Century Justinian and we're going to be looking
at much more closely,
oh,
was a fierce anti Manasseh site or,
or Calcitonin Orthodox.
But his wife was sort of [inaudible] office side.
This may have been politic since they were both effective rulers.
Um,
the people who were in an office side could orient themselves to Theodora the
emperors and the Orthodox to just an N.
Ultimately this problem would be solved,
quote solved because the Arab Muslim invasion of the seventh century would take
over the side territories.
Again,
I hope I'm not giving away a secret by saying that are the most,
uh,
striking,
sweeping and dramatic event of the Mediterranean world or of the Eurasian
landmass of the period that we're dealing with arguably is the rise of Islam.
Mohammed's had hijera is,
uh,
in the,
um,
six,
uh,
six 30 to six 33.
I can't remember anybody know offhand.
Um,
anyone want to look it up off hand.
H,
e,
g,
I r m
six 22 six 22 by six 60,
um,
Egypt,
Syria,
uh,
Palestine,
Lebanon,
ah,
have fallen to the Muslim to Muslim rule and um,
uh,
they are,
extending their power as far west as North Africa and as far east as a
Afghanistan.
How this happens,
why this happens is the subject for discussion a little later.
But again,
if you refer to the map in 600,
this is before the,
uh,
Islamic takeover.
And again,
if you look further east,
but eastern Roman Empire or consists of all these parts,
many of which are about to be taken away from it
and the parts that were taken away from it,
we're pretty much the Manasseh side parts.
Okay.
So the fifth century is the story of the survival of the eastern Roman Empire.
Despite these religious controversies,
the early sixth century,
which we'll talk about in more detail,
is the story of the expansion of the empire to make a stab at reuniting by
conquering the West.
What had been the,
uh,
the single Roman Empire Justinian's empire
was overextended,
at least in retrospect,
this is a re conquest that at least,
uh,
consultants from a later generation would have said was a mistake.
And overexpansion
initially the main enemy of the Byzantine Empire after Justinian.
So in the late sixth century,
early seventh century would be Persia.
Okay.
But also at the same time,
the Byzantine Empire would start experiencing Danubian frontier incursions
attacks from the Balkans.
And here again,
as I said,
it's all invaders and heresies,
uh,
invasions from Slavs and a vars in the Balkans and the Persians in the east.
Okay.
In a five 91,
a revolution toppled.
The Persian ruler who peculiar oddly enough,
fled to Byzantium for refuge where the emperor,
the Emperor Maurice
helped him gain his threatened back
in five 91,
there was a peace between Persia and Byzantium and Byzantium seemed to have come
out of this terrible period of warfare of the late sixth century.
This allowed Maurice to turn his attention to his other front is Western
northern front,
where the vars were,
um,
uh,
a tremendous threat to him.
The [inaudible] a central Asiatic people,
um,
who come in through Central Asia into the Balkans and they carry with them to
some extent the slobs.
Uh,
the conventional portrayal used to be that the [inaudible] sort of lead the
Slavs the latter are kind of passive.
Uh,
it's a little more complicated than that be a vars had taken,
um,
uh,
the great cities of the Balkans and in four 92,
Maurice turns to deal with them,
to push them back against the Danube.
His army rebels against him and,
um,
uh,
he's overthrown and killed.
The beginning of the seventh century is the period of the maximum danger of
Byzantium.
It lasts with intermittent flashes from six o two,
the overthrow of Maurice to seven 17,
the Arab siege of Constantinople.
Okay.
Immediately,
this new emperor focus
is attacked by Persia,
the Persian king claiming to revenge the murder of his benefactor,
but in fact simply reopening the war with Constantinople
in,
um,
six Oh eight six oh nine,
the Persians and the [inaudible] are allied.
And the Persians are really on the march.
By six 17.
They have taken Egypt.
They have taken Syria,
they've taken Jerusalem,
and the relic of the Holy Cross,
uh,
has been taken back to the Persian capital.
The emperor at this time [inaudible]
okay.
Whom Wickham is not very impressed by admittedly a heretically is,
uh,
leads a resistance as does the patriarch to a siege bad is on both sides of the
city of Constantinople.
On the one side,
the land side,
the Theodore ocean walls or the vars and the Slavs on the boss for us across the
city on the Asian side of the Bosphorus are the Persians.
And what [inaudible] does is to confine,
confide the city in the care of the patriarch and uh,
go off and attack the Persians from the rear.
The patriarch defends the city,
not only by organizing the army,
but by putting wonder working icons on the walls to face the enemy on icon is a
painting of a sacred figure.
Uh,
it's,
so then it is not a statue but a painting and it portrays a saint or Mary or
Christ and in what has come to be called the orthodox tradition.
These remain today a figure of the church,
a very distinct kind of aspect of the piety of the east.
The church,
the patriarch a ordered that the church melt down all of the treasures that had
been given to it to decorate it in order to pay for troops.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the combination of the icons,
the money,
the,
uh,
spirit of the populace and military means,
oh,
we're able to withstand this prolonged siege,
uh,
at times a double siege of the Persians on the one side,
the vars and the Slavs on the other side,
after many years of fighting in the east,
Heraclitus succeeded in overthrowing the Persians
at the battle of Nineveh in six 27.
So this is a 17 year war or so.
Yes,
I'm sorry.
Nineveh,
e h paraclese defeats the Persians and the Persian empire is virtually,
uh,
it's crippled.
Six 27 is an team would have seem to have been triumphant the first Arab
attacks.
However,
we're in six 30 for 12 years after Mohammed's had gyra
by six 36,
Syria had been taken by six 38.
Jerusalem had been taken and the true cross again,
uh,
in this case,
um,
uh,
we lose sight of it.
Persia itself would collapse in six 40 and pass under Arab rule.
Egypt would fall in six 45.
What's left of the empire then?
Is
the Balkans,
Anatolia,
some Armenian,
some Slavic,
uh,
elements.
So weak.
Is this empire so beset by enemies?
Does it seem to be
that a successor of heretically as the emperor Konstanz the second moved the
capital to Sicily to the west
calm stands the second ruled from Syracuse,
Syracuse,
Sicily,
obviously the original Syracuse,
he would be the last emperor to visit Rome.
And he was actually the first,
since four 76.
So in six 62,
when he moved the capital to Sicily,
we have the spectacle of a kind of ghost emperor visiting a ghost city
visit of constant is the second to Rome and the,
um,
severe crisis of the eastern empire beset as it was now a particularly but not
exclusively by the Arabs.
And indeed in six 74,
the Arab fleet appeared off Constantinople
in six 78 we here,
uh,
for the first time of the weapon of the Greeks against the Arab fleets,
a weapon called Greek fire.
Greek fire is some kind of flaming projectile.
Now their words,
something that you can shoot with a catapult or some other propulsion device
that will burst into flame.
Obviously you,
you can't launch it if it's already burning.
You have to have something that,
I mean,
yeah,
this is the essence of,
uh,
um,
basic,
uh,
bomb throwing.
You have to have something that is,
uh,
not going to,
you know,
that will explode on impact.
Uh,
Greek fire,
uh,
was,
um,
particularly effective on wooden ships and on rigging and sales.
It would set the ship's on fire.
Uh,
and it's a weapon that seems to have been a unique,
at least for awhile to the Byzantines,
but paranthetically how was it that the Arabs have a navy in the first place?
These people who decades before had never seen a river that flowed all year
long,
uh,
who had no experience with,
the c for whom the desert was the sea.
It is an example of this kind of very rapid adaptability that we'll emphasize
when we come to talk about the Islamic invasions.
The East did survive even this attack
the seventh century.
We will be dealing with in more detail is a crucial turning point.
By this time,
the eastern Roman empire were talking about as the East is pretty much a Greek
empire,
Justinian would be the last emperor to speak Latin
and the truncation of the empire with the loss of Egypt and the Near East means
that it is pretty much a Greek empire.
And also pretty much an orthodox empire.
Orthodoxy is the Christian faith that stands between Nestorianism and
monophysitism for the time the Orthodox world and the east and the Catholic
world in the West are the same.
They're official break won't I'm until 10 54.
And as you know,
uh,
to this day the Orthodox churches of Russia,
Greece,
uh,
and so forth look very different.
Um,
and they also have certain duct trinal differences,
uh,
with the,
um,
the west.
That's not our subject for the time being.
We do have,
however,
before the close of business,
one more heresy,
a heresy that starts to divide the Byzantine Empire in the late seventh century.
And that is iconoclasm
iconoclasm which Wickham talks about in some detail and which he tells us to
take seriously.
What he means by that is that iconoclasm seems to be something that must not be
about what it seems to be.
It's got to be about something else.
ICONOCLASM is the belief that image is like icons in particular,
uh,
are dangerous and that bay lead to inappropriate worship of the image rather
than what the image symbolizes.
Okay?
So the iconoclasts believe in banning images of persons,
okay,
Lacrosse is fine,
but not a picture of a saint.
Even in some circles,
pictures of Christ would be suspect.
The danger of this reverence paid to icons is that the icon then becomes a
sacred thing in itself and you're,
you fallen into idolatry,
you're worshiping multiple,
uh,
representatives of the divine.
Okay.
Now it's certainly seems logical that this must have something to do with Islam
because Islam in its most monotheist manifestations frowns on and bands the
representation of a purportedly divine figures.
And it indeed doesn't like figure all representation at all in decoration of
sacred spaces,
lest this be interpreted as exalting figures.
Even the prophet at especially the Prophet himself,
there are no pictures of Muhammad for home consumption,
for mosque display.
And so it seems logical that this is a response to criticism from Islam that um,
uh,
Christianity is really not monifieth and monotheist that it's a form of idolatry
because it has so many sacred figures and that the success of Islam and the
success of the Arabs against Byzantium now might be caused by the abandonment of
Mano a Mano,
atheism and the abandonment of the worship of one God and the proliferation of
multiple gods.
The problem is that there's no real evidence of this
and um,
you don't have to have Islam to force this kind of thing.
If you look around the churches of much of northern Europe,
you will see statues that have been decapitated by Protestants in the 16th and
17th century or stained glass that was destroyed by Protestants.
Protestantism is icon of clastic in many of its forms.
In that it believed that the Catholic Church was superstitious,
paid reverence to all of these saints and human figures and forgot in the
process to concentrate on the single God.
ICONOCLASM is a crisis of the empire.
It is also like these other heresies,
a recurrence of this problem of how to represent the connection between God and
human beings.
What connects the divine with the human?
Are there intermediaries?
Is Christ an intermediary or is he god,
and if he's God,
how is their intermediation?
Why does God care about us?
How does God care about us?
How many
ways are there to approach him?
It took until eight 43 to settle this controversy.
I mean,
it had many periods of settlement and then a record essence.
It's a controversy that lasts then something on the order of 150 160 years at
times and divides the empire completely.
At times not.
It tends to be supported by the emperor.
The emperor isn't iconoclast.
It tends to wane.
It's supported by the emperors,
partly as a way of trying to unify on mobilize the empire around the figure of
the emperor instead of dissipating the energies around the various saintly
figures.
So where are we with this,
uh,
empire that seems to consist of only sieges and barbarian peoples and heresies
in the ninth century would seem that the cities with the exception of
Constantinople itself have declined to become little more than fortresses.
We seem to be at the end of classical antiquity in some fundamental way of that
society built around Mediterranean cities.
Society,
even here as in the West is rural.
There's not a whole lot of trade.
They're still our libraries with books in them,
but they don't seem to be read very much.
We have very few texts from this era.
It's a militarized society.
It's an intensely religious one.
There's very little secular literature really at the end of Greco Roman pagan
knowledge
as it happens.
However,
this period would usher in an era of surprising,
at least in retrospect,
prosperity,
uh,
for the Byzantine Empire.
And we will be talking about that later on Wednesday.
We're going to discuss the reign of Justinian,
uh,
through copious and in as a thing in itself.
And then we will turn to the postdrome and world of the West subsequently.
Thanks very much.